Joe Biden just launched an attack ad
where he criticizes Pete Buddha judges
lack of experience compared to his own
here's just a piece of the criticism
take a look Joe Biden helped lead the
passage of the Affordable Care Act which
gave health care to 20 million people
and when park-goers called on Pete
Buddha judge he installed decorative
lights under bridges giving citizens of
South Bend colorfully illuminated rivers
that's a realize that's a real ad and I
guess Joe Biden saw that maybe that was
having a bit of success so now Joe Biden
is doubling down he's going even further
with his attacks on Pete Buddha judges
experience check out this ad Biden
released earlier today the Honorable Joe
Biden proudly represented the state of
Delaware beginning in the year 1973 what
was Pete Buddha judge doing in 1973 oh
yeah he wouldn't even get around to
being born for another nine years
classic procrastinator and when senator
Biden was writing the anti-drug Abuse
Act of 1986 where was Pete Buddha judge
sobbing because he thought his uncle
really did steal his nose and cultural
criminy was chairing the Senate
Judiciary Committee in 1990 what was
Peabody judge doing soiling himself at a
piano recital gettin buried and finally
in 1994 to abide and valiantly
spearheaded the Violence Against Women
Act
pee poo de jedge doesn't even like women
well not in that way and you I know what
I mean
I mean romantic and if anything Joe
Biden likes women too much wait don't
include that way yeah
roll to business
[Applause]